even this is the result for the Yeovil
constituency I in Clark packed in
returning officer for the Oval
constituency declared that the total
number of votes cast across the Ural
constituency at the UK parliamentary
election on the 8th of June 2017 was
fifty nine thousand four hundred
ninety-eight the total number of ballot
papers rejected was ninety four the
total number of votes given to each
candidate was as follows
Marcus John Hudson fish the Conservative
Party candidate thirty two thousand
three hundred and sixty nine Ian James
Martin Labour Party seven thousand four
hundred eighteen Katie Pritchard
independent 919 Joe Randall green
Liberal Democrat seventeen thousand six
hundred and forty six Robert Charles
wood Green Party 1052 therefore I give
public notice that Marcus John Hudson
fish is duly elected as the Member of
Parliament for the oval constituency
[Applause]
well it is a great honor to be here and
to be re-elected I would just like to
say some thank yous I'd like to thank
the returning officer I'd like to thank
the police for their sterling efforts
we've all been very conscious I think
these last weeks of what an amazing job
they do to keep us safe and I know that
they have worked very hard here over the
last few weeks to make sure that that is
the case here and I know they will
continue to do that I also want to thank
all of the counting staff here tonight
for your amazing work this is a lot
quicker than last time I have to say I
wasn't expecting it to be over quite so
far so really well done and thank you
also to all of the staff of all of the
polling booths all over the district
you've all done a fantastic job I also
want to thank all the members of my
association I really couldn't have done
this without you my agent Kate my
campaign manager Jenny and I want to
thank of course all of the good people
of the oval constituency who voted for
me and all of the good people who didn't
all also I will certainly fight
incredibly hard for all of us to get the
opportunities that we deserve here in
the southwest at this really crucial
time for our country clearly we don't
know yet exactly what the result is
going to be nationally and it could be
an interesting week or two but I hope
that we can get a an increase in our
overall majority and that we can have a
clear path ahead I also just lastly also
want to say thank you from the bottom of
my heart to my darling wife Jenny and my
two little girls IO and Ellen who have
been incredibly patient and incredibly
loving and giving of of their time and
the time I have with them for me to do
this
I love the hold of the constituency but
I particularly love that little
so thank thank you very much indeed
[Applause]